[Music]
Broadway shows don't last forever but
some of the costumes used on stage can
get a second act thanks to a
not-for-profit organization called the
TDF costume collection we have a dress
from wicked one by alpha as well as one
of the Mamma Mia jumpsuit that's Steven
coverall the director of the collection
which is based in a story of Queens
TDF accepts donations from various
theatrical performances at the end of
their run and rents them back out to
other performances for reuse we do
approximately a thousand productions a
year renting over 10,000 costumes both
here in New York City as well as
nationwide they have over 80,000 items
in their collection including shoes
shirts dresses hats gloves and various
other accessories a lot of times when a
Broadway show
will eventually close the costumes are
usually retained for the tour or backup
but every once a while a Broadway show
will say okay we're sort of done with
these clothes you can have them TDF
started back in the early 70s when the
Metropolitan Opera moved to Lincoln
Center and donated costumes from 22
shows TDF has since expanded offering
all sorts of items donated from a
variety of performances and individuals
recently we received a rather large and
very exciting donation Hollywood
Broadway fashion designer Bob Mackie
some notable pieces Mackey donated were
a dress worn by Julia louis-dreyfus
at the 1997 Emmy Awards and an entire
production of the best little whorehouse
goes public
when the original production of rent
finally closed after running for many
many years we were very fortunate to
receive all of the original costumes
from the original off-broadway
production before it moved to Broadway
we received many donations over the
years from Mamma Mia when Mamma Mia was
on Broadway we have addressed one by
Jane Krakowski from a recent production
of she loves me some costumes worn by
Patti LuPone in the revival of gypsy
well
the items are iconic you won't
necessarily find something worn by big
celebrities like cher or Barbara
Streisand
many celebrities actually want to hold
on to their costumes either to
potentially open a museum or more likely
later on in life have some sort of
celebrity auction many amateur stage
performances rent from TDF but so do
some TV shows and movies satellite live
when they are filming depending on their
season and their needs is in here
sometimes every week
TDF costumes can be seen in this skit
with Betty White and this skit with
Justin Timberlake as Mozart both Birdman
and 12 years of slave featured costumes
in the film that were rented here from
the TDF costume club the only type of
rental that we really don't do is
Halloween our costumes are really not
Halloween worthy we also try to avoid
doing rentals where there's any food or
beverage involved anyone can go in and
explore the collection but if you want
to try anything on you have to fill out
some paperwork first they have
mannequins you can use to check sizes
and dressing rooms you can book in
advance cost is based on a whole look
not per individual item the other part
of our pricing exists with number of
weeks of performances and how large your
theater is you also have to pay to have
the costumes dry-cleaned before
returning them Stephen says they have a
green strategy in place to make sure all
the items get as much used as possible
once an item gets too ragged its moved
to a special area where these types of
items are in demand we have a distressed
section so for productions like lame is
or Urinetown
these are costumes that need to not look
so great and two or three times a year
they open up the warehouse for a special
bag sale you pay for that bag you go in
and whatever you can shove into that bag
and take out the door is yours so no
matter what condition a costume is in
there's always a chance at an encore
performance
[Music]
sometimes I'll put costumes on people
and there's like nothing nothing changes
that just kind of like and then you put
costumes on people that brings out a
whole other personality or two and it's
kind of fun
[Music]